there's a kind of nuclear power you may
not be familiar with similar to atoms
colliding in the
sun that's nuclear fusion and it could
revolutionize how clean energy is
produced on Earth we actually have to go
hotter than the sun but as a new wave of
experiments heats up can Fusion live up
to the
[Music]
height
in the heart of the English Countryside
seems like a typically quaint
Village you probably wouldn't know that
the area is home to a cluster of energy
companies all trying to turn an
ambitious idea into
reality I'm working in an industry
that's doing incredible things that
offers the promise to decarbonize
countries and industries for the
future for more than a decade toac
energy has been working on a dream to
make nuclear fusion an important source
of global energy the promise is that
Fusion could give the world carbon- free
near Limitless energy forever and when
we get the gyrotron whereabouts is that
going to be in relation to the device
you know everybody in any news flow is
seeing the impact of climate
change and we need green energy that can
provide what Fusion can provide which is
base load power when you need it on the
grid in an industrial setting to
decarbonize nuclear fusion would also
work in any weather unlike solar and
wind and create far less nuclear waste
than today's nuclear power plants it is
remarkably efficient so one kilogram of
Fusion fuel is equivalent to 10 million
kg of fossil fuel
so what is nuclear fusion today's
nuclear power stations use nuclear
fishion where heavy elements are split
into fragments nuclear fusion is the
reverse it's a process inspired by what
happens in the
sun here you have hydrogen atoms
colliding and fusing they form helium in
the process and they emit a neutron and
it's the neutrons that carry the
energy actually have to go hotter than
the sun six or seven times hotter than
the sun to 100 million de C and also
exerting pressures from very very high
field magnets so it's a small wonder
that scientists have been trying to make
fusion work for a long time around 70
years the key requirement is a reactor
which can create the extreme conditions
needed War's team uses the most tested
kind called a toac within that toac we
heat up a plasma and then we feed it
with fuel in a commercial device that
fuel is dyum and tritium and they're the
two isotopes of hydrogen that Collide
and create
Fusion in 2022 toac energy heated plasma
to 100 million de c a record for this
kind of toac and the temperature a
fusion power station will need in the
future
but so far no Fusion experiment has
managed to produce the sustained energy
needed for a power station toac energy
aims to achieve this within a decade to
bring Fusion to the Grid in the 2030s we
have to overcome a number of
challenges we have achieved great things
in the science we still have some
engineering challenges to overcome in
the fields of Material Science liquid
metal to help overcome the challenges
toac energy and other companies have
some useful Partners just a few miles
away near the village of here
scientists working for the British
government have been running Fusion
experiments with European partners for
40 years we're just down the road from
Cullum that campus has UK atomic energy
Authority there but also a number of
private companies and we work very
closely developing the talent that we
need for Fusion in the future so this is
the place to be right now if this much
hyped energ source is going to take off
this Fusion between the private and
public sectors may offer the best hope
we now have a cluster of activity a
whole load of other research facilities
and also companies using our facilities
we have General Fusion a Canadian
company moving to our campus we have
first light fusion and toic energy both
UK born companies building their next
facilities here collaborating with our
people and that helps all of them to get
there quicker
frankly in the last decade the number of
few Fusion focused private companies has
rocketed growing to at least 42 around
the world and attracting more than 6
billion dollars in investment
Commonwealth Fusion systems in America
is backed by Bill
Gates and Jeff Bezos has invested in
general Fusion which is using a
different kind of reactor to a
toac this diversity of approaches
increases the chance of fusion making it
to the grid there are no guarant es but
Fusion's potential to transform energy
production makes it worth the energy
maybe even all the energy in the world I
came to Fusion to make a difference to
the world since I was 18 I was convinced
that we needed to do something about
climate change and provide low carbon
sources of energy I still believe that
Fusion is the best pathway that we have
and we need to make fusion
happen hi I'm Charlotte Howard executive
editor at The Economist if you'd like
read more about the energy transition
please click on the link opposite and if
you'd like to watch more of our now and
next series please click on the other
link thanks for watching and don't
forget to
subscribe